any more
second amendment fans in the house huh
any more second amendment fans in the
house huh
want is that a trick question this is a
party right
invitation only for those who bleed red
white and blue
so [ __ ] off
chill just want to have a good time
drink a beer smoke
this look like a [ __ ] neighborhood
picnic to you jim
you're a little tense something wrong
problems at home oh you're a jokester
huh
you looking for a good laugh yeah we all
want a good laugh walker
such a nice day everyone having a good
time like a little fourth of july
be ashamed to tell gunner someone [ __ ]
it up you know
yeah i know fine
that's much whom go drink enjoy yourself
celebrate that decent score yours
you got some kind of competition going
on yeah
led spitting kind i won in
[ __ ] out of luck we're about to call it
what
you scared i'd leave you all in the dust
do you know who you're [ __ ] talking
to
hmm i've been deployed three times
three i fought on the front line
easy walker what'd i say huh
we're just here to have a good time you
got something to prove be our guest
it'll be fun let's shoot the [ __ ] out of
holt
just as i thought you looked to me like
a show-off
let's see what you got now this ain't
your average shooting match
you got to have a good eye but an even
stronger head
because because we all drink around
before
each shot to gunner the new boss in town
i like the sound of that anything else i
should know
four stations you shoot at the targets
with holt's face and the time limit
the more bootlickers you pop the better
high score so far
belongs to walker 43
lights you beat him prize is yours
enough talking let's shoot take this
revolver
use it if you want your shots to count
we're testing skill not tech here
go ahead to the first station we'll
start whenever you're ready
break a leg
yeah 12 seconds go
no no no no just don't go past the line
when shooting
automatic disqualification
stop time's up next station
hey hey vodka first then you blast hold
a new one
i'm telling you man the breeze whoosh
throw it all off oh the hell is this
rubbing on there guys shoot you got 12
seconds
you cross that line you're out of the
game
but i said my fingers live you had your
chance rudy
and stop this station
down the hatch together
uh you got 12 seconds go go go
hey throw that line we don't like
cheaters here
stop investigation
one more round drink
i'm gonna throw up
oh so warm what else would it be in this
heat
shoot 12 seconds don't forget the line
one two over and you're gone
that's it go check your stats
ugh
now let's see
third place middle of the road
not bad for a no-name little punk
and for the winner with gunners
congratulations
usa and now
let's drink sixth street sixth street